thank you for your patience I know so
many of you have written me comments on
YouTube Twitter messages asking me to
make an update to the coronavirus video
that I made two weeks ago but I didn't
want to rush it there's been so much
misinformation out there there's been
limited guidance from the CDC in the
w-h-o in the last week so I didn't want
to rush it and release a Wednesday check
up too early so we're doing this on a
Sunday and I asked you to give me
questions that I can answer about the
corona virus let's get started I'm
jumping into the most uploaded ones and
we're going from there this video is
being filmed on February 28th 2020 it's
important for you to know the date so
that you know the information here is up
to date up until that date Ananya sharma
the w-h-o released a statement today
where they have said the global risk of
the spread of kovat 19 virus is very
high how many more such levels as the
virus have to cross to be declared a
pandemic
first of all let's define terms here
epidemic means an outbreak of a virus in
a specific region that is losing control
pandemic is worldwide meaning it's
happening multiple countries and it
spreads easily this very high level is
the highest level they have I believe
it's from stage one to four and the very
high classification is stage four so
essentially we might as well function as
if this coronavirus outbreak is a
pandemic because in reality is in so
many countries it's being spread it's
gonna continue to spread so we might as
well call it what it is a pandemic SNK
should I be worried about flying should
i cancel my next trip overseas also I
love you thanks bye I appreciate the
love it depends it depends honestly
where you're flying we've seen outbreaks
now happen in Italy South Korea China
Japan we obviously need to be more safe
than we usually are when we travel
meaning we should be more vigilant about
washing our hands proper hygiene not
touching our faces and if we're sick
definitely not going anywhere
if I had a trip scheduled to one of
these countries or at least a nearby
country I would not go I would try and
push my plans unless it was absolutely
necessary I needed to be there it's just
an unnecessary risk at this time but
it's about weighing the risks or
benefits that's what we do with every
single medical decision Pez princess how
long does the virus stay on objects
someone said six hours someone
at six days I don't know who to believe
right now well the truth of the matter
is we don't have exact data as to how
long the virus survives on solid
surfaces what we have done is we've
looked at its cousin viruses the
previous SARS virus MERS virus and
they're similar in that they're both RNA
coronavirus viruses and they seem to
live on solid surfaces for only hours at
a time
the main spread of these viruses comes
through respiratory droplets not surface
spread six days sounds too extreme to me
so if I had to lean one way or another
six hours is probably more more accurate
of an estimate yo its Kate besides
washing my hands what else can I do to
protect myself so it's not just about
washing your hands but it's also about
washing your hands the right way you
have to use both soap and water you need
to do it for at least 20 seconds sing
happy birthday twice over that's a good
little hack that you can have or you can
use an alcohol-based hand sanitizer but
it has to have at least 60% alcohol
content for it to be effective
ii don't touch your face eyes nose
because that's how the virus spreads
from your hand into those organs
we don't want it entering our body and
that's one way we can protect ourselves
the third is trying to keep a distance
away from those who are sick now we
don't have accurate estimates how far
this virus can spread when you're away
from another person who may be carrying
it but the more distance you can keep
between you and someone who's sneezing
and coughing the better you're gonna
fare tareq huggy have any of the people
diagnosed with corona virus recovered
absolutely 80% of the cases that we've
diagnosed of the corona virus have been
mild cases where people absolutely do
recover deadly curse TV Hong Kong
detects low level of kovat 19 virus and
patients dog in quotes is there any
truth in this look I read this story and
the w-h-o did confirm that there's a dog
being held in quarantine but it tested
it for a low level of the virus and the
dog wasn't even infected meaning it
wasn't showing symptoms so what they
think is likely going on is the dog may
have come in contact with its owners
saliva or respiratory droplets that were
found on the dog's mouth and nose it
doesn't mean that the dog was actually
infected at this point I have not seen
any evidence showing this virus can
spread to dogs so no need to pet
Alex Coryell should we be keeping
younger kids at home should everyone
avoid going out well Alex first of all
I'm not sure where you are in the world
in the United States my recommendation
would be to listen to the CDC and local
health authorities for example where I
practice right now I look at the New
Jersey Department of Health for guidance
as far as whether or not we should be
closing schools temporarily having
certain students stay home but until we
get such notices from these agencies I
think it's best to wait and continue
business as normal because again the CDC
reiterated that the risk at this very
moment for those in the u.s. is still
low Vanny Javita they said flu shot is
one of the preventive measures for this
virus is it true doc I haven't heard
that getting the flu shot actually helps
you fight off this virus any more
effectively than without the flu shot
however you should most definitely still
get your flu shot because the flu is a
very serious virus on its own that can
cause respiratory issues leading to
pneumonia and even death in some cases
so yes get the flu shot because the last
thing you want is to catch this novel
coronavirus get a mild case but while
your immune system is busy fighting that
off you get the flu on top of it EMA
Plaza is there anything you can take to
boost your immune system that actually
works and I'm so glad you asked this
question
I see countless ads on Instagram on the
internet of people trying to peddle some
sort of supplement that's gonna boost
your immune system and protect you from
this virus that is absolute poopoo there
is no such thing as an immune boosting
supplement look if you want to keep your
immune system healthy get vaccinated get
seven to nine hours of sleep
consistently every single night eat
healthy exercise follow proper hygiene
and that's the best thing you can do for
your immune system ignore people trying
to make a buck in this situation in fact
those who are doing so should be ashamed
of themselves
am i GZ is there a cure for kovat 19 or
something that reduces the chances of
getting infected
well MIG we're actually working on this
twofold first is the vaccine we're
hoping hoping to get a vaccine next year
mid to late next year's gonna be the
earliest that we're gonna be able to get
a vaccine out and
this is one of the fastest turnaround
times we've ever had for a backseat now
in terms of treating or curing this
illness we have like 80 clinical trials
going on right now testing different
medications like antivirals anti
retrovirals HIV medications even taking
blood plasma from patients who've
recovered and have antibodies to this
novel coronavirus and injecting it into
other people
we're legitimately trying all these
different therapies in trials to figure
out what works Big Smoke
as a doctor yourself are you worried on
what's going to become of the kovat
19:00 virus not gonna say I'm worried
I'm gonna say I'm thinking about the
worst possible scenarios and trying to
get prepared for it in fact that's what
every major hospital institution in the
United States is doing as well and we're
doing a good job at that
we're refreshing our personal protection
equipment policies we're learning what
questions to ask patients what is the
ideal route for a patient to come into
the office to get properly tested where
should they be in isolation we need to
make sure we get all that information
wrapped up every healthcare provider is
aware of that
so we can give the best possible
treatment to our patients random person
how contagious is this coronavirus well
the preliminary research shows that for
every single person that gets the novel
coronavirus two to three and a half
other individuals will become sick and
that with it as well which means that
it's moderately infectious for example
for the flu the common flu that we see
in the u.s. here for each person I get
sick one other person will get sick so
you could say that it's two to three
times more infectious than the
traditional flu
Gabrielle Harkins do you think this
virus will mutate and become worse
Gabrielle this is a hard question it's
very difficult to predict some viruses
do mutate initial reports for this novel
coronavirus is showing that it does not
mutate rapidly the current cases have
not changed much from the genetic
strains of the initial cases that being
said if a virus mutates it does not
always mean that the virus mutates and
becomes worse sometimes a virus can
mutate and actually eliminate itself so
we need to keep abreast of the situation
and see what's changing what we need to
do about it and trust only quality
sources like the CDC and w-h-o Joanne
Val Vidal is it true that the corona
virus can be treated by the H I
medication well Joanne Val that's a
great question cuz there are clinical
trials ongoing to see if the HIV
medication works so far we do not have
results for those studies I am waiting
as soon as I find out the results of
some of them I will keep you updated
nimrat Gil dr. Mike what is the real
name of the corona virus and what does
it mean and I sort of confused you guys
on the previous video the disease that
this novel coronavirus causes is called
Co vid 19 now it's called Cova 19 it's
okay to say Co vid 19 virus right
because there's a virus that causes
kovat 19 it's the disease just like the
HIV virus causes AIDS the virus itself
thus novel coronavirus has the name SARS
cold - so the SARS Cove - virus is like
HIV covin 19 is like aids so Cova 19 is
the disease SARS Cove 2 is the virus xmx
Jade if Yuri had the corona virus are
you immune to it this is actually a
great question and something that we're
putting more resources into learning
about we have seen some individuals who
were infected with this novel
coronavirus
get reinfected at a later point
generally speaking when a individual
gets a virus what happens the body
creates antibodies to fight off this
virus called IgM after that the body
signals the release of IgG antibodies
which are known as memory antibodies
now for each illness the body has a
different time frame of how long they
keep around these IgG antibodies for
example if you get chickenpox usually
that's a one time illness because your
body builds lifelong immunity other
illnesses like the flu it's not lifelong
especially because the virus mutates
each season for measles if you get your
measles vaccinations that's considered
lifelong immunity we don't know how long
do you need he lasts when you get
infected with the corona virus but it
should be that for at least a certain
period of time that you do have some
immunity to it Colton Schwartz are
people in the u.s. that the possibility
of it's spreading like it is in China
the possibility certainly is there in
fact my recent television appearances
the anchors have been asking me the same
question what's the deal with community
spread because there was a single case
in California where we had an individual
who tested positive for the corona virus
without Expo
to someone from an area where the corona
virus is present or someone actively
sick in those situations we label that
community spread in this situation
research is still ongoing to figure out
how that person was sick so we're not
labeling a community spread just yet
we're suspecting that it's community
spread I'll give you an example but
patient comes into my office with the
influenza virus and I diagnosed them
with the influenza virus I don't go and
do an investigation of how they got it I
just say hey you got it from the
community so we label it community
spread if community spread starts
happening meaning that there's patients
that are coughing and sneezing walking
around and they're not being quarantined
and put into isolation properly that can
cause a huge uptick in cases something
else that could be going on which we're
just learning about is that there's some
patients that are having asymptomatic
spread of this virus meaning that
they're not showing symptoms the virus
is in an incubate
which we're saying lasts anywhere from 2
to 14 days huge range at which time
where they can possibly spread the virus
but not show any symptoms that could be
problematic on one hand but also
positive on another meaning that there's
a lot of cases we haven't diagnosed yet
which will lower the lethality rate of
the virus making it less dangerous so we
have to figure it out we have to wait
and we have to not rush to look at
numbers every single day those numbers
will change those numbers will grow one
day shrink another let's look at
averages let's look at guidance from
trustworthy sources like the CDC and
w-h-o and go from there check out my
video of me playing plague Inc now you
may laugh why am i recommending a game
where you're infecting the world but it
actually teaches you a lot of lessons
about how viruses like this spread
definitely give it a click and stay
happy and healthy
[Music]